après une pause en raison de
l'incertitude sur son financement c'est
officiel le chantier du nouvel hôpital
trousseau à Tours va enfin pouvoir
démarrer la décision était suspendue à
une rallonge financière de l'État alors
quel projet quel calendrier pour
l'hôpital sont directement par intérim
nous répond bonjour Richard Amazon
bonjour vous êtes donc directeur par
intérim du CHU de Tours ça fait trois
mois vous vous occupez ce poste mais
plusieurs années déjà à l'hôpital avant
de revenir sur le projet il est donc
évoqué une rallonge vous préférez le
terme de financement complémentaire vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi 100
millions d'euros environ de la part de
l'État c'est ce que vous avez chiffré
pour un coût total pour ce nouvel
hôpital trousseau d'un demi milliard
d'euros vous êtes très bien placé pour
connaître que le contexte de rigueur
budgétaire touche notamment l'hôpital
public est-ce que vous avez toutes les
garanties que ce financement
supplémentaire sera effectivement versé
et dans quel délai alors nous avons
effectivement toutes les garanties
nécessaires pour engager l'opération de
travaux de ce qu'ils vaisseau amiral de
cette opération de restructuration qui
est le nouvel hôpital thononceau c'est
c'est simplement un seul ensemble d'une
ensemble d'une opération de
restructuration qui en comporte
plusieurs puisque le but c'est de passer
de 5 sites à moins de sites du CHU on va
y revenir effectivement
tout à fait donc l'hôpital dit feu vert
vous y allez vous pouvez démarrer les
travaux c'est ça
100 millions d'euros comment vous l'avez
chiffré et comment ça va se traduire
dans le budget de l'hôpital alors 100
millions d'euros est une estimation de
l'aide complémentaire dont nous aurons
besoin pour réaliser l'ensemble des
opérations ça ne peut pas être très
précis parce que tout le monde connaît
la situation inflationniste du pays qui
nous rend difficile la prévision
budgétaire donc on aura peut-être besoin
de moins où on aura besoin de plus selon
l'évolution de la situation budgétaire
de l'hôpital c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas
de chiffre précis dans le courrier du
ministre mais qui nous assure de son
soutien jusqu'à la hauteur de
l'opération donc ce qui suppose
évidemment sauf financement vous avez
droit à un certain déficit que
résultats comblera c'est ça au final on
nous rassure tout le droit d'investir à
hauteur des 522 millions d'autorisés
pour l'ensemble des projets donc on
comporte plusieurs on a engagé la
psychiatrie les la presse en été fait
écho donc ça c'est un bâtiment qui est
rentré dans l'enveloppe que nous avions
prévu donc ces travaux sont engagés le
bâtiment sortira fin 2025 et nous avons
fait les travaux de terrassement de
Trousseau ça n'a échappé à personne les
normes trous qui est devant l'ancienne
hôpital trousseau et donc là nous
attendions l'autorisation d'engager les
travaux donc c'est cette autorisation là
que le ministre nous a écrite suite à
une demande de la gouvernance du CHU
relayée par un ensemble des locaux du
territoire important
mais c'est vrai qu'ils se sont engagés
je les remercie de leur soutien ainsi
que le président du conseil de
surveillance donc Emmanuel Denis le
maire de Tours trois sites au lieu de 5
aujourd'hui voilà l'objectif de ce
projet
immense trousseau Bretonneau et
Clocheville pour la pédiatrie avec comme
objectif final de rationaliser les soins
c'est ça l'idée absolument l'objectif
initial c'était de donner les bonnes
filières patients je prends un exemple
assez coutumier quelqu'un qui fait un
accident vasculaire cérébral et
transporté en hélicoptère sur le site de
Trousseau mais l'activité de neurologie
et sur le site de Bretonneau donc il
repart en ambulance sur le site de
Bretonneau bien là avec le nouvel
hôpital trousseau on regroupe les soins
critiques les urgences et la chirurgie
sur le même site et donc on donne des
gains de chance au patient avec une
ouverture pour 2028 c'est bien ça 2028
quelles activités resteront sur le site
Bretonneau sur le site de Bretonneau il
y a tout le reste en pratique donc femme
enfant le bâtiment Olympe de Gouges la
cancérologie la médecine le rapatriement
de l'Ermitage donc avec les activités de
soins de suite et puis le troisième pôle
comme vous le disiez c'est le site de
cloche vide qui lui ne peut pas bouger
dans l'immédiat on ne peut pas le
financer et donc on va en assurer la
modernisation comment on l'a fait au
cours des cinq dernières années à
nouveau pour 12 millions d'euros pour 12
millions d'euros merci beaucoup Richard
d'Amazon est devenu ce soir sur notre
plateau merci à vous